ooh it's a nerd balls it's a nerd wars
it's the all-female edition who we got
so today I'm nerd warriors we're gonna
be doing some girl-on-girl action with
Elektra vs. Barber Crofton now yes thank
you XD minus X deficit Adam can't talk
don't be offended he's done a couple of
them already we used one of them keep
sending them post them if you got more
anyway yeah well I'm gonna be arguing as
always the side of comic books and I'm
sorry there's no way that Laura Croft
could be an electric she's an
accomplished martial artist she's an
assassin assassin she's come back from
the dead
alright so is Laura you know how many
times I died playing the original tomb
raider mostly because the camera
controls around look at me
whoo there you go that's that's half the
argument right there she comes back from
the dead all the time but she can die in
a puddle of water and I will say this
Electric's got a worse outfit Elektra
Elektra doesn't even wear paint and in a
combat boots I don't know there's
something about combat boots and a knife
that just mm yeah arable so you see
here's the thing with Laura Croft all
right Laura Croft is a nobody enough
she's awesome she's got big Botox he
lives six kids the most attractive
husband on the planet that's an elite
bread that's Angelina Jolie that's not
even Laura Croft whatever okay okay fine
what fine Angelina Jolie playing Laura
Croft beets what's her face as Electra
no we're not gonna talk about Jennifer
Garner yeah no no no yeah no Angelina
Jolie's way hotter than Jennifer Garner
hell yeah Angelina Jolie why is it every
year she looks more and more like a
walking skeleton it's like Skeletor
she's like female what's this what's
this that's magic everywhere what's this
what's this I'm Angelina Jolie what that
you know like Jack Skellington she used
to be so hot eat a sandwich yeah when
she was in Gia oh my god if you haven't
rented you go ready to go Electra
yeah played by Jennifer Garner Angelina
Jolie wins check no that's not an
argument over you know over no over over
here's the thing here's the thing
halfway through the fight with Elektra
all right
Angelina Jolie would have to stop so she
could make out with her brother at an
awards show
a good point but that'd be hot no that
was it was a brother dude I don't care
see show making out their tongues in
each other's mouths I don't care so she
should I don't know them it was hot that
she was just kissing on the screen she
had sex with Billy Bob Thornton oh
that's a good point that's point electro
right there yeah that is white electric
point Lara Croft
electric couldn't handle Billy Bob
Thornton what huh yeah uh Laura Croft
came out alive she did a second movie oh
yeah yeah what do you mean she couldn't
handle Billy Bob Thornton what you
couldn't handle Billy Bob Thornton he's
not just your run-of-the-mill criminal
that dude is crazy oh no no no no no no
there's the fight jennifer aniston
versus um Angelina Angelina Jolie who
would win in a fight right now
Angelina Jolie Angelina you really think
she's got this bowling ball she just
like yeah but she her bat can't even
support him anymore Jennifer Anne seems
to be doing fine every time I say wrong
Jennifer Aniston his kept in really good
shape she could she would just yeah
Jennifer Aniston like have you seen her
when she gets mad she turns into the
Hulk mm-hmm yeah she-hulk actually know
just know she hopes you slide you can
see Jennifer Aniston and whose stomach
just growled yeah that's not true
I made a little fart Oh different
Electra wins all right if you got
suggest and stick them down here I'm
gonna throw one out there if anyone can
do this well we will definitely use it
any character played by Vin Diesel any
character created by Stanley
you